[Musica]
vitale
berlino
dove siete finiti perché sono stoppa
[Musica]
con berlino sta tenendo
questo
alla paghetta di ieri
un nuovo messaggio
scampia e pop hit sott'acqua
questa è la challenge di oggi
[Musica]
bellissimo queste gonfiabili comodissimo
beh io dormo fa da irene ciao ciao
berlino berlino interessato a questo
gonfiabile
vorresti mangiarlo vero per
ciao a tutti
eccoci qui aiuta il mento vista
trasporta vita dall'altra parte youtube
egli è fermarmi vitale
inventarmi vuole portare via
ti aiuto io ad affondare ecco come sono
tornato
ad affondare
eccomi qua the hawthorn assistenza
sociale e che si doveva cambiare hip hop
it volta acqua rosa a fondarsi aiuto
ok ora siamo pronti per la challenge
scambio copit ma è anche sta facendo
vitale
buttiamo giù vitale
ho captato il gonfiabile
[Musica]
se cosa alla fine del video dovrete
scrivere secondo voi che ha fatto gli
scambi migliori ovviamente la sede in
piazza entro 5 secondi
[Musica]
il mio preferito terzo
cambio fallito voglio più bambino il
polipetto andato anch'io voglio più
parli non è giusto
[Musica]
i biglietti farle scambiato a
quarto grado 3 1
il
momento vincendo non lo so ci sono tanti
i pochi che mi piacciono come
il coccodrillo il gran cetto l'attacco è
più difficile vedere i pochi se tu quasi
intera un 3 2 1
[Musica]
che è caduta la camera per terra
e come scambiare i pop hit band
alberghiero non si vede niente
dopo vediamo che ha preso i compiti più
belli si sa che sto sono più fortunato
io ora vedremo due pura
[Musica]
perché non è accettato il mio
triceratopo
perché la mia paperelle più bella crisi
mi dispiace per te ma non è tutto
ok allora non lo scambio
che cosa è cambiato non ho visto niente
fosse qualcos'altro di più carino
è troppo divertente
ultimo round 3 2 pura
[Musica]
come ultima prova proveremo a darsi un
bacio sott'acqua secondo voi non era
secondo me sarà un disastro programma 32
[Musica]
riproviamo
32 ora
[Musica]
riproviamo l'ultima volta
unità
ma ti sei dimenticato che dobbiamo far
vedere hip hop il sì è vero allora io
sono qua nella vasca da bagno perché non
posso stare fuori dall'acqua quindi
questo è il mio nuovo eletto non avete
visto gli episodi persino intentate poi
a vederli comunque questa challenge io
ho preso la balena e il polpo il pesce
rosa che sapete dalla scorsa challenge è
uno dei miei preferiti
questa è quella di questi voleva
liberarsi da in quale challenge militare
ha vinto per tale da scrivetelo nei
commenti vediamo se avete visto che fino
al trinity poi la incuria bellissimo
preso il limone e ovviamente la cover ti
ho preso il coccodrillo
pinguino di b b valero di un casco di
banane a questo pensa di mettere così in
testa il famoso casco di banane il
grechetto che mi piace un sacco quello
che aveva detto di no allo scambio
all'inizio mi sembra davvero e poi
dovuto dare due pochi di più ma ero
sott'acqua
con l'arco
quella batteria
scambiare
che cosa negativa color arcobaleno
piccolino
il mio preferito potrebbe diventare
questo ma rimane comunque il tocco
diretto da michael arcobaleno anche
l'altro balena euro tra i miei preferiti
e dei miei preferiti
proviamo a fare canestro
tributi
ritirati nei nomi avast che anche il mio
letto vuol dire
[Musica]
peggio per te che i miei occhi addosso
di legge qualcosa questa ragione
prossimi giorni ci stupiremo steve
manipolate che ora io oso tipo
obiettività e faccio per te che per
dimagrire
e tonificare permette in entrate video
mi cade su quella che preferite buone
ambizioni
[Musica]